[Musique]
dans l'exposition vous donne une carte
d'embarquement à l'entrée vous êtes là
vous êtes votre petite carte et vous
arrivez à la fin dans la salle où il y a
tout le nom de tous ceux qui ont disparu
et ceux qui ont survécu et là vous
découvrez tout à coup si oui ou non vous
avez survécu ou pas donc ça vous touche
c'est juste c'est une façon de rentrer
dans la vie d'autrui
[Musique]
c'est tout le mystère qui a autour tout
ce qu'on sait pas et qu'on essaie
d'imaginer de la souffrance aussi qu'ils
ont pu ressentir
ouais il y a tellement de choses qui me
fascine suite au film en 98 j'ai acheté
plein de bouquins en anglais
des bouquins anglais américains français
sur le sujet ça m'a toujours beaucoup
intéressé et puis là avec l'actualité ça
a été relancé donc avec la disparition
du Titan
[Musique]